we're hearing a brand new in sync song
how did that come about obviously when
we started working with Justin and
recording and there was this journey of
boy bands you know we wanted to
celebrate that era of music but also
poke fun at it he texted me while I was
walking my dog and he said I think I
found the song and I want to bring
insync back together to do it so I
screamed
and and then we talked on the phone and
I then I screamed again on the phone but
um it was yeah it was amazing the whole
process he you know reached out to the
band we pitched them the story they were
all really into it the biggest covert
operation we've ever had at Dreamworks
Animation